Her low freak bitches faces were born for sure.
They can take more impact,
wider faces,
bigger heads,
thicker.
Next for sure.
They get absorbed better.
Everybody can get knocked out,
right?
Because the human bodies is so flawed,
especially if you have like some crazy ouster Overeem type character kick you in
the head.
Anyone can get knocked out,
but it's less likely to get knocked out if you're shaped a certain way and your
hands,
the shape of your hands makes a giant difference as well.
It's like how much impact you can deliver.
Like if you have some other times with us,
a George Foreman had an enormous hands,
like there's a guy named Francis and gone.
It was like one of the top UFC heavyweights.
Every time I shake his hands,
I just go,
Jesus,
he's got these fucking hammers,
like these giant hammers and he just knocks people dead.
He,
it's a huge advantage.
Structural advantage.
It's like the difference between having a ball peen hammer,
a little tiny hammer for nails and having a sledgehammer.
It literally is the difference.
You know?
It's just having that extra weight on the end as a,
especially if there's a lot of,
uh,
you know,
a lot of body mass behind it as well.
Just a massive there to be no gloves.
He'll look at his hands the size of his mother's.
Yeah.
They're enormous.
Ah,
that's Brian stand by the way.
Who was the UFC or the WC 205 pound champion.
Okay.
He,
uh,
was a UFC fighter atop top UFC fighter at 185 pounds.
He's a big boy.
He and his arms get dwarfed by in Ganos hands.
Looks like a stump.
Yeah.
So that,
that is an undeniable physical advantage if you can land that punch
more dumbed head.
Yeah.
There's a lot of shit going on.
But my point is that if fights had no pads,
we would get a more accurate representation of what the body can really do.
Instead,
we're making fighters get more damaged because you're letting people tee off.
I don't think you should be able to tape your risks either.
I think that's unfair too because you can't gives it to make it stiffer so it
doesn't buckle as much when you impact something cause we hit something.
If your hand goes like that you can really fuck your wrist up and then you
really get torn tendons,
all kinds of shit like cement and their gloves and stuff.
They have.
Yeah.
Margarito did that.
He um,
he was fighting um,
a bunch of different guys and busting them up really bad.
And then before his fight with sugar,
Shane Mosley,
they caught him in the locker room with plaster in the wraps of the gloves.
Somebody caught him and then they started putting two and two together and
realizing like when he beat up Miguel Cotto when he beat up all these different
fighters,
it was an unusual beating.
Like he was hitting them and it was just having an un,
an ordinate inordinate effect on them,
like hitting people way harder than anybody else was.
No one could figure out why.
Once they took that panning out
the way worse because Lance Armstrong was doing that when everybody else was
also doing that.
No one else was putting too much and people are gonna start getting suspension.
Well,
they weren't,
he wasn't necessarily beating everybody,
but he was beating a lot of guys and the way he was beating him,
he was fucking them up.
And then when he got to sugar Shane,
they caught him with the plaster.
They took it out.
Rewrapped his hands and sugar.
Shane beat the fuck out of him and sugar.
Shane knew about it.
Everybody knew about it.
They were talking about it on the,
uh,
on the broadcast and that they were almost not letting him fight and they let
him fight with new Emily wrapped hands and sugar.
Shane just lit him up like a Christmas tree.
Fucked him up.
And then Manny Pacquiao fucked him up to everybody fucked him up.
Why do you get to,
I mean,
I guess he should've been,
he should've been probably retired from boxing.
They should have said there's no way you could ever fight again.
Just like we want to see you get killed a couple of times.
Yeah.
I mean he was never the same guy and he actually wound up fighting.
He had a really badly torn retina to the point where I think they put an
artificial retina from one of the beatings that he took I think to sugar Shane.
It might've been a pack.
Yeah,
it might've been the packout beat him,
beat him bad.
It was a couple of guys beat the fuck out of him,
but it's just that guy was putting plaster and his gloves so I'd have something.
Gloves are the way to go.
I mean if you want to do it for boxing,
I get it.
Boxing is a completely different sport and there's an art to catching punches on
the gloves and,
but my thing about MMA in particular is why is it okay to elbow someone in the
face but it's not okay to have gloves that are like bare knuckle.
That's crazy.
You could literally smash someone's fencing this and this.
Yeah,
you could smash someone's head when an elbow like right in their eye socket and
that's totally legal.
You could smash their nose to a pulp that's totally legal,
but some are like a shin.
You get hit someone so hard with your Shin.
It's a razor blade ultimately will it's a baseball bat kick someone in the head
with a shin.
It's crazy.
There's no padding out of it at all,
but you have to have patty and your fists.
That's crazy.
Is that it's old.
We left.
It's when the UFC first came about,
it was beer and alcohol and then in in some sort of a,
you know sort of concerted effort to turn into a legitimize sport and be
accepted by athletic commissions.
Pretty new,
very new in terms of like big time sports.
It was started in 1993 so just 20 something years old,
24 years old.
So they want it to make it look like in the beginning of the first fights that I
saw in 97 when I first started working for the UFC,
there was a lot of bail,
bare knuckle fighters.
Guys a fault with shoes on.
They were bare knuckle.
You were allowed to grab people's crotches still you would rather grab their
clothes are Kelly?
Yeah.
Not that a little different.
You were,
you were allowed to do a lot of shit.
You could pull hair for a long time in this area.
And then they finally got rid of that.
They got rid of grabbing clothes.
But um,
you didn't have to have knuckle a padding on your knuckles back then.
And the people that were super successful realize you can hit people way harder
if you have patty on your knuckles.
So Vito Belfort was one of the first night he was 19 years old and you enter
into the UFC,
UFC 12 Dothan,
Alabama in 1997 and just beat the fuck out of everybody with gloves on.
What would it take for them to do a role that said no gloves anymore?
They would just have to listen to me.
Yeah.
And listen to a lot of other martial arts fans.
Some people wouldn't want it because they think he would get cut more,
which I think you would,
you would get more superficial tissue damage.
But I think ultimately you'd get less brain damage,
I think,
uh,
because you can get hit.
I think you'd get hit less.
And especially if you practice correctly,
I think you could,
I mean you would still run the risk of getting elbowed indeed and kicked and
it's not safe by any stretch of the imagination.
Do you think it has to get to a point where because MMA so young,
we're fighters or 60 and they're blowing their brains out and doing what that
have helped players are doing.
Anybody would,
I don't think people would have to know.
I don't hear about a concussion crisis and then I made that much,
but it's real.
I mean any sort of combat sport you're going to have it.
No,
I mean I know it's there,
but it's not like in the zeitgeists really at the moment it isn't yet,
but it certainly could be and it probably certainly will be when some of the
veterans getting into their sixties and seventies and we start to see them like,
do you ever see Joe Frazier before he died?
He was on the back of my throat.
He was on opiate Anthony Show and he,
it was so bad.
His is slurring and this inability the payment was on Howard.
It was like Floyd Mayweather.
I don't think he's showing any signs.
Yeah,
that's just how he talks.
Maybe it's just 5:00 AM 5:00 AM nervous talking Howard street trying to get it
together
or talking to Howard and you know probably has zero calm left in his box.
I was banging all night long.
Right.
For sure.
Too much common his mouth.
What does this,
they have a CT tests.
They think a Boston University they found a biomarker they think that can let
people know now ahead of time,
time before your Bell Rung three times and they sort of know that already know
cause it's not,
it varies upon the person.
Some people are way more durable for some reason they don't know why and it
could be also connected what we're talking about before,
the actual shape of the head,
the thickness of the muscles of the neck,
the ability to keep the head from snapping back too much.
How many times it actually happens,
how good you are avoiding things and roll.
Some people get hit and then they learn how to roll with stuff and it takes a
tremendous amount of the impact.
Off.
So you think would MMA fighters are in their sixties and seventies and it's like
not looking good?
They might consider,
I don't think they're going to consider it because I think to the general public
gloves mean safer gloves means sport fans of Evan may want safe.
They um,
it,
well you got,
I would say if you're talking about public opinion,
you're going to have a lot of the people that aren't really fans that are also
going to weigh in.
Right?
So if you have public opinion,
should they take the gloves off?
MMA is going to be a lot of people out there arguing passionately that have no
idea what they're talking about loves me and more dangerous and they will say,
no way.
It's already barbaric enough.
It's really what we should concentrate on.
Just putting more pads and more safety procedures and stopping fights quicker
and looking out for the safety of these athletes.
But I think much like how pads and football probably caused more injuries to
players.
Helmets,
rugby.
Yeah.
I think the same thing should be said about MMA.
I think anathema to your logic of like helmets and pads cause injuries.
Yeah,
it really does because think they prevent them.
That's the only thing that it does any different.
It doesn't like if I had to choose between finding someone with him and made
gloves,
a fighting,
someone bare knuckle and with like I get hand wraps and then I'll be like,
yeah,
wrapped me up.
Yeah,
wrap me up.
You could just tee off on somebody.
It's a totally different experience.
If your hands are fragile,
a lot of times guys will hit each other with the palms of the hands instead
because you don't want to break your hands.
Get on top of someone.
You could smash their face with a palm of this.
The hardest part of your hand hit things hard with a palm and it doesn't hurt at
all.
Right?
Yeah.
It's a different kind of a bone to come.
Thick bone and it's used to touching and pushing against the hardest part of
your body,
your elbows,
maybe your knee and your elbow.
Yeah,
they're real hard.
I mean,
you can't really break your elbow,
I guess you've probably seen people break shit all the time.
They break chunks off the bottoms of their elbows from fighting.
Yeah.
I've had friends that have to get surgery where they have like floating bone
chunks from elbow and people in the head that you chip off little pieces of your
elbow.
That's not great.
Okay.